we do get a lot of those messages from  kids saying i will model for you for  free and i'm like why would we want you  to model for us it's gonna cost you yeah  that actually costs us that's enough do  you guys get this i'll come work for you  for free i'm training you for free  that's what it sounds like it's like  when they watch those hustler videos  they're like you know what you gotta do  is you gotta learn how to work for free  man and then when you work for free then  you just [ __ ] learn hey i wanna work  for you i'm [ __ ] hustle and then  they'll watch like uh some tick tock  video like like two days into working  for you where it's like if you're  working for free you're getting ripped  off i'm like yeah i'm getting [ __ ]  scared  no i need to get a paycheck man i'm not  respecting myself  but you get a good two days of free work  yeah yeah yeah